make a big bold move shock everybody
change the look of your eyes let people
see a new set of eyes because you have
finally faced yourself and you've
addressed your courage you've addressed
your vice you've addressed your issues
you are no longer embarrassed of
yourself you no longer have nothing to
hide you are free and guess what the
good news is tomorrow's a new day
and guess what else is the good news
tomorrow is going to be an incredible
day moving on this year's gonna be an
incredible year my life's gonna be an
incredible life I'm gonna have the most
incredible relationships I'm gonna have
the most incredible friendships I want
to make incredible amount of money I'm
gonna go see the world I'm gonna have
fun I'm gonna take care of my health I'm
gonna feel good about this cat so with
the 75 to 90 years that I have in this
existence I'm gonna give value back and
leave a legacy in the world and they're
gonna remember the mark I left in this
world you go do that